Дорожнього знака ще не видно, а відомий додаток з навігації
попереджає: слід пригальмувати.
Увага! Попереду радар контролю швидкості.
З червня 2020 року в Україні діє система фото- та відеофіксацій
порушень правил дорожнього руху.
За три місяці водії вивчили розміщення камер та навчились гальмувати перед ними.
5 разів попадався - 5 разів платив. Є знак.
Попереду машпни гальмує. Хочеш чи не хочеш, і ти теж пригальмовуєш.
Менше ДТП все ж таки відчуваєтьсья.
Я ставив на телефон додаток.
Але він спрацьовує пізно.
Той, хто порушує, все одно він попадеться.
Бо додаток спрацьовує, коли камери вже тебе "зловили".
Втім, вцілому ситуація на дорогах все одно стала безпечнішою,
впевнений патрульний Олександр Сікач.
Він два роки фіксує швидкість на дорогах за допомогою пристрою TruCam.
Каже, після появи камер спостережень  "шумахерів" стало в рази менше.
Так в перші тижні камера фіксувала до 50 тисяч порушень на добу,
а нині - 10 тисяч.
З фото- та відеофіксацією набагато краще.
Менше спілкування з громадянами,  більше фіксуються.
Громадяни самі слідкують. Не ми слідкуємо,
громадяни самі намагаються слідкувати за своєю швидкістю,
а не їхати швидко.
Нині на українських дорогах встановлено 50 камер спостереження
Про кожну попереджає відповідний дорожній знак,
а з повним переліком адрес можна ознайомитись на сайті Патрульної поліції.
На думку експерта з питань транспортного моделювання Дмитра Беспалова,
така відкритість є недоліком реформи.
Тепер, коли водії звикли до відеоконтролю на дорозі,
значно дієвіше і дешевше було б встановлювати так би мовити фейкові камери.
Так, наприклад, економлять європейські країни.
У Вас є обмежений бюджет, і ви купуєте  корпуси від камер,
які коштують набагато дешевше, і просто раз на місяць
і просто раз на місяць без повідомлення, де саме стоїть справжній прилад,
просто запускаєш цей прилад.
Тоді 20 комплексами можна покрити 100 локацій.
Людина буде психологічно пригальмовувати
Бо не знає, чи справжнє обладнання, чи ні.
Система фото- та відеофіксації
для України не нова.
Такий спосіб контролю порушень ПДР запровадили в 2010 році.
Втім, тоді його вдалось зупинити через Конституційний суд,
який визнав неконституційною практику притягнення до відповідальності  автовласника.
Адже відповідальність має нести порушник, тобто особа, яка була за кермом.
Тож адвокат Богдан Глядик не виключає,  що й цю реформу оскаржать в суді.
Окрім того, каже адвокат,  й досі не вирішене питання з водіями,
що користуються машинами за довіреністю.
Тут Кабмін дуже суттєво недопрацював.
Бо закон, який впроваджує автофіксацію,
він в перехідних положеннях передбачав одну дуже важливу норму.
Що протягом місяця з дня вступу цього закону в силу,
Кабмін був зобов'язаний повідомити усіх без виключення автовласників,
які автомобілі за ними зареєстовані.
Якщо б цю вимогу виконали, то за 5 років автовласники
могли б вирішити цю проблему, знайти цей транспортний засіб,
встановити його місцеперебування, провести реєстраційні дії,
щоб змінити юридичного власника.
Але цього не зроблено, і сьогодні  з цим великі проблеми.
В патрульній поліції про ці недоліки знають.
Проте не вважають, що вони завадять реформі розвиватися далі.
Наразі завершують закупівлю ще двохсот камер.
Усього ж за два роки планують встановити близько тисячі камер на дорогах країни.
З часом ті фіксуватимуть не лише порушення швидкісного режиму,
але й порушення правил паркування та виїзд на зустрічну смугу.
Боротимуться й з "винахідливими" порушниками.
Спеціальні нанесення. У нас навіть було,
що повністю номерний знак був затягнутий чорною плівкою.
Взагалі нічого не видно було.
Чомусь вважали, що це захист від фіксацій.
Там захист від всього. Якісь сітки, якісь 3Д плівки
які мають переломлювати кут, під яким відбивається світло.
І всі інші моменти.
Навіть доходило до того, що з дерева зірвали листочок
і закривали одну цифру  на номерному знаку.
Є такі випадки, ми з ними боремось.
За три місяці українці сплатили 95 мільйонів гривень
штрафу за перевищення швидкості.
Утім, показником безпечності на дорогах є  передусім зменшення смертності на дорогах.
А на ці показники камери спостереження поки не вплинули.
За останні сім місяців на українських дорогах
загинули тисяча сімсот людей - це вже на сто осіб більше,
ніж за відповідний період минулого року.